the young woman who survived a Taliban  attack on her school bus in Pakistan is  now a UN messenger of peace Malala  yousufzai is the youngest person to  receive the UN Secretary General's  highest honor we sat down with her and  she had a message for President Trump  about America's acceptance of refugees  so it's important that he understand  that these people are in need and and I  have seen them I went to refugee camp  and I think he needs to go to these  refugee camp you think President Trump  needs to go to a refugee camp I  definitely agree with that  president Donald Trump needs to go and  see refugee children he needs to go and  visit the refugee camps he needs to know  what a real life is like in a refugee  camp we also spoke with the Nobel Peace  Prize recipient about the humanitarian  crisis overseas her push for girls  education and her own plans now for  college she's 19 years old we're gonna  bring you the full interview tomorrow  that's only here on CBS this morning